hello I'm Lillian here's my question I'm
wondering what can I do with science
outside of science class science is such
a fun thing I just want to know what
more I can do with it
thanks Lillian oh my goodness science is
the most fun you can have you're right
what can you do out of class well you
can fly model planes you can get a
magnifying glass and look at everything
Lillian take a magnifying glass up to a
tree leaf it's amazing
it's amazing all the detail all the
stuff that goes on in a leaf that most
of us never even notice our blade of
grass then the other thing I used to do
for hours was watch ants I don't know
where you live but man I used to watch
ants all day they're absolutely
fascinating but on what they're doing
they're in a hurry they brush antennae
and they keep going they got stuff going
on man
they're doing ant things the study of
ants by the way is given humankind
tremendous insight into humankind
this is to say the genes that you that
we all share we're all so much alike
affects the way we behave toward each
other and this behavior is very in many
ways similar to the way ants behave it's
crazy it's fascinating what else let's
see get a balloon and see if you can
make it fly and get a hairdryer and a
plastic bag and something to hold the
bottom open and see if you can make it
fly that's something you do outside in
the summer especially then catch
rainwater and then look at the rainwater
with your magnifying glass it's amazing
it's amazing the stuff that goes on we
just don't even notice see if you can
lily and I'm looking at you in the
camera see if you can watch the color of
your skin change over the summer even if
you're constantly putting on sunscreen
if you're like your parents are
relentless spraying you down with
sunscreen see if the color of your skin
like the back of your hand is a good
example see if it doesn't change over
the course of summer and then watch it
change back at the end of the summer
watch the moon
it's amazing it's amazing people don't
realize why the moon changes shape as
seen from the earth and and most people
do not know the phase of the moon they
don't know the shape of the moon right
now but maybe you will and of course
there was a time when everybody knew the
shape of the moon because we didn't have
streetlights we didn't have lights at
night and so everybody was aware of how
much light there be my grandparents
would tell you exactly when the moon was
going to be what shape my parents maybe
not so much people I went to school with
no way because there's more and more
light we talked about planetary science
we talked about life science I think we
talked about physical science with
flying a balloon then chemistry should
do some chemistry
oh yeah well mixed vinegar and baking
soda put Mentos in a soft drink but do
it outside because stuff goes everywhere
it's fun that'll be big fun Lily and
have fun with science outside all summer
watch the moon
you